>> Jesse: HELLO, EVERYBODY, I
AM JESSE WATTERS.
HARRELL JR., MARTHA MacCALLUM,
GREG GUTFELD.
IT IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
PRESIDENT BIDEN GETTING HIS
HANDS DIRTY WITH SOME SERIOUS
MIDTERM ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
SO WHERE IS THE MEDIA AND
DEMOCRAT OUTRAGE?
THE SAUDIS ARE POSTPONING OIL
CUTS UNTIL AFTER THE MIDTERM IS.
IN AN EFFORT TO KEEP GAS PRICES
DOWN.
I'M NO HISTORIAN, BUT DIDN'T
SOMEBODY ELSE GET IMPEACHED FOR
THAT?
DESPITE HIS EMBARRASSING
COURTSHIP, THE PRESIDENT IS
VOWING TO REASSESS OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE OIL-RICH
NATION.
LOOKS LIKE HE WAS WRONG WHEN HE
SAID NOBODY MESSES WITH BIDEN.
>> WE FIND OURSELVES IN A
POSITION, AS BEGGARS, THE MOST
POWERFUL COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WILL DO
ANYTHING TO TRY TO KEEP GAS FROM
INCREASING.
GOING TO DICTATORSHIPS LIKE
VENEZUELA, PLEADING WITH THEM.
ALIENATING LONGTIME PARTNERS IN
PLACES LIKE SAUDI ARABIA AND THE
UNITED ARAB EMIRATES.
>> Jesse: IF YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS DONE REASSURING THE
SAUDIS, STAGEHAND.
>> WE ARE ABOUT TO TALK TO THEM.
>> IN WHAT WAY, SIR?
>> STAY TUNED.
>> Jesse: IT DOES NOT STOP
THERE.
BIDEN IS STRAIGHT UP LYING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, SAYING THAT
HE IS MAKING SKYROCKETING
INFLATION BETTER.
MAKING THE ABSURD CLAIM ABOUT
REPUBLICANS IN AN ATTEMPT TO
SWAY THE MIDTERM VOTE.
>> WE HAVE GOT AN ELECTION IN A
MONTH.
VOTERS HAVE TO DECIDE, DEMOCRATS
ARE WORKING TO BRING DOWN THE
COST OF THINGS AND TALKING
AROUND THE KITCHEN TABLE.
YOUR CAMPAIGN EVERY DAY, UNDER
THE AGENDA TO RAISE YOUR COSTS.
REPUBLICANS WIN, INFLATION IS
GOING TO GET WORSE.
IT IS THAT SIMPLE.
>> Jesse: MY THIGH, ARE YOU
SEEING ANY SIMILARITIES WITH
WHAT HE IS DOING, AND WHAT TRUMP
WAS ACCUSED OF DOING?
>> Martha: I FIND IT
REMARKABLE THAT THERE IS NOT
MORE ATTENTION TO THE STORY,
THAT HE, ESSENTIALLY, ACCORDING
TO THESE REPORTS, TRY TO MAKE A
DEAL WITH THEM.
IF YOU CAN PUSH THIS OFF, I
DON'T WANT TO SEE THIS.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE HELPFUL,
AND IT GETS ALMOST NO COVERAGE
AT ALL.
THE THING THAT REALLY STRIKES ME
IS THAT SAUDI ARABIA OBVIOUSLY
IS A COMPLICATED PLAYER APPEARED
VERY COMPLICATED.
THE ENEMY OF MY ENEMY SORT OF
SITUATION.
THEY HAVE HELPED US AGAINST
IRAN, SEE YOU CANNOT BLAME THEM
FOR NOT DOING WHAT HE WANTS HIM
TO DO BECAUSE HE IS SITTING DOWN
AT THE TABLE WITH IRAN, THEIR
ARCHENEMY, AND THEY HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR YEARS, SO THIS IS
NOT AN AREA WHERE HIS
DIPLOMACY -- IT HAS FAILED
MISERABLY.
THE LAST TIME WE WENT BEGGING TO
SAUDI ARABIA AND OPEC TO PRODUCE
MORE OIL WAS IN THE '70s UNDER
JIMMY CARTER, SO THIS IS A VERY
BAD LUCK.
WHEN HE DOES THAT THING THAT HE
JUST DID -- JUST WEIGH IT.
STAGEHAND.
IT IS LIKE YOU JUST CONCEDES THE
WHEELS TURNING.
IS THERE A PLAN HERE?
I GUESS HE HAS GOT A GRAND PLAN.
>> Jesse: SOMEONE HAS GOT TO
TELL JOE WHAT THE PLAN IS.
>> Greg: WHAT WERE THOSE
THINGS BEHIND HIM?
IS THAT HUNTER'S BEDROOM?
[LAUGHS]
ANYWAY, YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO
THAT, MARTHA.
[LAUGHS]
>> Martha: I THOUGHT HE NEEDED
IT.
>> Greg: THE MEDIA FREAKED OUT
OVER TRUMP ALIENATING -- THE
FEAR THAT TRUMP WOULD ALIENATE
OUR ALLIES, ESPECIALLY WHEN HE
TOLD GERMANY NOT TO RELY ON
RUSSIAN OIL.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
NOW JOE IS USING MILITARY
SANCTIONS AGAINST WHAT I WOULD
CALL AN ALLY, JUST TO ADJUST
THEIR TIMING SO THAT THEY CAN
HELP IN THE MIDTERMS.
TURNS OUT THAT TRUMP IS A
PSYCHIC, AND JOE IS A PSYCHO.
WHENEVER THE DEMS ACCUSE YOU OF
SOMETHING IT IS BECAUSE THEY
WERE ALREADY THINKING OF DOING
IT, AND HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED
OVER THIS BECAUSE WHAT IS GOOD
FOR THE GOOSE IS GOOD FOR
THAT...
>> GANDER.
>> Greg: YES.
HERE IS A HUGE DIFFERENCE,
THOUGH.
THE TRUMP IMPEACHMENT HAVE THE
FULL BACKING, AND THE BIDEN
IMPEACHMENT WANT.
EVERYONE WILL LAUGH AT YOU.
NOW WHEN WILL THE PULLING THEIR
HAIR OUT AFTER THIS BECAUSE THIS
IS TEAM SPORTS.
REPUBLICANS, THEY DO NOT LIKE
EXPLOITING PROCESSES FOR
DARKNESS.
THEY LIKE THE PROCESS, EVEN IF
THE GOAL TURNS OUT -- EVEN IF
THEY LOSE, THEY STILL LIKE THE
PROCESS.
DEMOCRATS ARE LIKE NO, WE WILL
EXPLOIT THE PROCESS.
WE WILL IMPEACH THE CRAP OUT OF
YOU.
REPUBLICANS GONE MAYBE THEY
SHOULD ONLY BE USED WHEN IT
MATTERS, SO THE REPUBLICANS
PROBABLY WILL NOT IMPEACH
JOE BIDEN, WHICH IS -- I GUESS
THAT IS JUST THE WAY THAT IT IS.
>> Jesse: WE'LL JUST IMPEACH
HIM FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
NOT THIS.
HE IS INVITING ELECTION
INTERFERENCE, HE IS EXPLOITING
THE COUNTRY'S NATIONAL SECURITY.
HE'S PUTTING THEM IN DANGER BY
NOT SELLING THEM WEAPONS, JUST
FOR A POLITICAL WIN.
IT IS EXACTLY THE SAME THING
THEY ACCUSED TRUMP OF.
>> THEY WILL NOT IMPEACH HIM
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID OF
KAMALA HARRIS BEING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WHAT IF HE COULD NOT EMOTIONALLY
HANDLE IT, AND IT WOUND UP
BEING -- I AM NOT EVEN GOING TO
SAY IT OUT LOUD, BUT
KAMALA HARRIS BEING THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
WOULD YOU SAY TOUGH GUY?
I AM NORTHER TOUGH, NOR A GUY,
BUT I DO KNOW HOW ONE WOULD ACT.
IT IS NOT THIS -- NINCOMPOOPING
ALL OVER THE UNITED STATES.
YOU GO TO SAUDI ARABIA AND SAY,
RATHER THAN SAYING, PLEASE DO ME
A FAVOR, PLEASE DON'T CUT YOUR
OIL PRODUCTION.
YOU SAY I'M GOING TO DO YOU A
FAVOR, HERE JESSE, EV
SAUDI ARABIA.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, I WILL.
PERMISSION TO BE SAUDI ARABIA?
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO CUT YOUR
OIL PRODUCTION.
I WILL NOT OPEN OUR SPIGOTS WIDE
OPEN AND START PUMPING ALL OF
THAT DELICIOUS NATURAL RESOURCES
AND JUST FLOODING THE WORLD WITH
NATURAL GAS AND OIL.
SEE?
I WILL -- YOU ARE TO DO THAT,
AND THIS IS A FAVOR I'M GOING TO
DO YOU BECAUSE WE, THE
UNITED STATES, COULD DESTROY THE
ECONOMY OF SAUDI ARABIA FOUR
YEARS AGO.
WE WERE A NET EXPORTER.
FIRST TIME SINCE 1949.
WE WERE IN THE SWING PRODUCER IN
THE WORLD.
WE CONTROLLED WORLD OIL PRICES
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE MOST EXCESS
PRODUCTION CAPACITY.
JOE BIDEN COULD DO THAT, BUT HE
WANTS BECAUSE HE IS OBVIOUSLY
BOTH THE MASOCHIST BECAUSE HE
LIKES TAKING IT FROM
SAUDI ARABIA, AND ALSO A SADIST
BECAUSE HE LIKES INFLICTING PAIN
ON THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Jesse: SO --
>> HE GOT IT FROM SOMEWHERE.
MAYBE IT WAS DADDY.
>> Jesse: DAGEN IS SAYING THAT
HE IS A TERRIBLE NEGOTIATOR.
WOULD YOU AGREE ON THAT?
>> Harold: I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THAT WE WISH YOU WOULD BE
MORE TRANSPARENT, BUT I DON'T
THINK THERE IS AN EQUIVALENCY
BETWEEN THIS AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
YOUR CONGRESS HAD PASSED MONEY
FOR DEFENSE OPERATIONS OR FOR
ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE, AND THE
PRESIDENT SAID TO THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT I WILL NOT RELEASE THE
MONEY THAT CONGRESS HAS ALREADY
PASSED.
SO THERE IS A DIFFERENCE HERE.
THESE KINDS OF NEGOTIATIONS GO
ON ALL THE TIME.
NOW, WITH REGARD TO SAYING I
WANT YOU TO DO THIS BEFORE THE
ELECTION, REMEMBER, THIS IS
IMPACTING THE WORLD.
GAS PRICES, ENERGY PRICES ARE UP
ALL AROUND THE GLOBE.
WHAT I THINK IS A BETTER LINE OF
ATTACK FOR REPUBLICANS, WE
SHOULD JUST BE PRODUCING MORE
OIL HERE.
WE SHOULD NOT FIND OURSELVES
HAVING TO BE DEPENDENT ON -- I
DON'T CARE IF IT IS A FRIENDLY
ALLY OUTSIDE OF THE
UNITED STATES WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING OUR OWN NATIONAL
SECURITY AND OUR OWN ENERGY
SECURITY, SO I HOPE WE PRODUCE
MORE OIL, NATURAL GAS.
WE DO ALL OF THE THINGS THAT WE
TALK AROUND THE STABLE IN TERMS
OF ALL OF THE ABOVE.
>> Greg: IT'S YOUR FAULT.
>> Harold: I THINK THAT'S A
BETTER ARGUMENT.
I DO THINK THE DEMOCRATS -- WE
ARE VULNERABLE IF YOU'D WE HAVE
TO PRODUCE MORE ENERGY PRODUCTS
HERE.
NOT BECAUSE WE ARE AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE, NOT BECAUSE WE
ARE NOT FOR A GREEN ENERGY
PLATFORM HERE BECAUSE WE ARE FOR
AMERICA AND OUR OWN NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WE ARE SEEING A PROXY WAR FOR
ONE REASON.
ENERGY.
>> Martha: PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
NOT FOR AMERICA IN THAT WAY.
>> Harold: HE IS CUTE
>> Martha: HE IS BEGGING TO
SAUDI ARABIA AND POTENTIALLY
VENEZUELA RATHER THAN DOING WHAT
DANA JUST SAID, TURNING ON THE
INCREDIBLE NATIONAL RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE HERE.
THE GROWING PIPELINE.
>> Harold: WE CAN DO THAT NEXT
WEEK.
I DON'T HAVE AN ISSUE WITH ANY
PRESIDENT SAYING THAT WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT OUR SHORT-TERM
ISSUES.
WE CANNOT HAVE THIS BETWEEN NOW
AND NEXT FEBRUARY.
>> Martha: HE IS HURTING HIS
OWN PEOPLE.
>> Harold: IT IS NOT A SPIGOT
THAT YOU TURN ON.
WE PRODUCE 3 MILLION GALLONS --
>> Dana: BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IS?
THE MINUTE YOU SAY YOU ARE GOING
TO DO IT, OIL PRICES START TO
DROP.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED UNDER
TRUMP.
>> Greg: WE WOULD NOT BE IN
THIS MESS IF IT WAS NOT FOR
JOE BIDEN, ARRANGING A COUP IN
UKRAINE.
WE PRODUCE MORE DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTS.
THE FACTS, WHAT THEY ARE.
>> Martha: WHO GOT TO
JOE BIDEN, THEN?
>> Jesse: COMING OUT, OH, BOY,
AO